またツイッターで日本語の失業とを行ってみました
私はいつ自分の生きがいを見つけますか来日することで自分の生きがいが見つかるって
いうのは幻想だとわかった時現代日本語を勉強する書は何ですか完全に絶滅する前に4
年間も使えたよって将来自慢できる事で
知らないお婆さんの日本語が分からなくてすみませんもう一度いいですかと聞いてみ
ましたが逃げられました
逃げられないようにどうしたらいいですかすみませんもう一度いいですか
わっあっていますただしそういう前に
マスクとサングラスをかける必要があります自分が外国人であることはば
れないように日本のことわざを教えてください
ことわざことわざにファンにはいろいろなことわざが今国ぞ
顔と技を知っている人が誰ですか
ことわざ
腐るでも木から落ちる日本人ていい子いいねの言語を学ぼうと思っていますか
つまり日本には英語以外の言語を教える教師の授業ってありますか
はい需要が一つありますなぜとなんでちがいってなんですかこれねこれよくある質問
です違いは
なんでって言う言葉の感じを決して忘れないけど何故っていう言葉の感じは頻繁に忘れ
てしまうっていうことです
日本で本当の友達を作る方法を教えてください
もうかなり簡単ですそこらへんもバーとかに行けば普通に友達が作れます
はい次の数米本とも友達って言ってたよなぁ
それは分からんはアニメになる方法を教えてくださいなるほどこれはあなたがアニメと
現実が違うっていう前提で生きてるからなんですよね違う一緒なんですよまずはアニメ
と現実が同じだっていう風に考えて行動してください
秋間からを買ったり家族と彼等
です彼の前で初音ミクの声っていいよなとか大胆に行ったりとかすればあなたもうも
自然にアニメになっていきますよ
いつもふりがなが帰ってやるから漢字を勉強する必要ってもうほんとないんじゃない私
の言っている事って間違ってますか
美容としていることよくわかります楽しいやっぱり
ちょっと間違ってますっていうのはいつも漢字に振り仮名が帰ってやるって言うよりは
漢字自体がカタカナの外来語に変わりつつあるのだと言った方が正確ですホンス点をし
ながら
言語学校に通うことって効果的ですか
a 言語学校に行かない限り日本にはいわゆるエコー団体
とかってありますかありますよよく歩道でチラシを配ったり
プラスチックに包まれた名刺を落としたりとかしてますこれを最後の質問にして
くださいやですしにくいとしづらいのちがいってなんですかこれもかなり簡単です先に
なり何しにくいを洗う
ことで正解はの件月詠から抜け出す方法を教えてください
努力を重ねてリネン眼を開眼すること
つまり自分の人生に責任を持って母語を話すこと以外に何かスキルを身につけること
神羅天征とか
ん ni